para algunos empezó como un pitido en
los oídos para otros como un dolor
intenso de cabeza pero todos tenían algo
en común eran diplomáticos de Estados
Unidos que desarrollaron una extraña
dolencia conocida como síndrome de La
Habana el primer caso fue hace seis años
un funcionario de la embajada de Cuba en
la Habana empezó a sentirse extraño
náuseas mareo repentinos migrañas y lo
que empezó como algo anecdótico terminó
preocupando a Washington tras que se
reportaran docenas de casos en países de
todo el mundo la primera hipótesis fue
que el gobierno comunista de Cuba estaba
detrás de los ataques con ondas
electromagnéticas por lo que el entonces
presidente Donald Trump retiro a la
mayoría de los diplomáticos de la Habana
pero ahora seis años después y sin haber
resuelto el misterio la tía finalmente
confirmó que ninguna gente extranjero
está detrás de esta si ntomatología
la mayoría de las agencias han llegado a
la conclusión de que es altamente
improbable que una entidad extranjera
sea responsable algo que aumentó
tensiones entre Estados Unidos y Cuba y
es que tras el retiro de Visas por este
tema los cubanos se han sentido víctimas
sin ningún tipo de justificación hay un
daño sufrido por la población cubana a
partir que sobre la base de acusaciones
infundadas Se tomaron medidas muy duras
que separaron a nuestros pueblos de Cuba
y de Estados Unidos a pesar de no haber
rastreado la raíz del problema este
sigue preocupando a Estados Unidos con
más de 1000 diplomáticos afectados en
todo el mundo en 2021 el presidente Joe
biden destinó una ayuda del gobierno a
Los afectados por el llamado síndrome de
La Habana